my name is Ephraim Isaac professor if
I'm Isaac I'm director of the Institute
of Semitic Studies in Princeton New
Jersey I've been a professor I had
worked for many years and other
institutions of learning I am here to
support you the concept that a
successful business has to be accepted
augmented with the culture and
spirituality in that respect I would
like to respond to mr. Haltom over
honest comment in which he says you
would like to see the end of internal
and external conflicts which take me the
lives and resources of the continent
this is exactly the correct stance I do
feel very strongly that if there are
conflicts internal or external there can
be no economic development no peace no
development of course and no development
also contributes to conflict therefore
it's my great hope and my great faith
that the people of Africa who actually
have a tradition of love and peace and
conciliation will wake up to the
necessity for intergroup dialogue
intergroup ritual respect
in order for us to be able to create a
successful economically successful
society in short we have to stop
conflicts within and without in Africa
then we will win we will have peace and
then we can also focus our energy on
development clean water food education
for the youth and we can bring a new day
for Africa